et maintenant mon tour par thébaux matin
quand on partait sur les chemins
les sifflets
firmin ya des français sébastien
fétis affirme-t-il
fait-il bon soir après laurent bâti et
vous vous êtes la fille du grand
champion cycliste jacques anquetil le
rival du fameux raymond poulidor de
notre enfance poupou l'éternel second
c'est vrai que vous avez dit poupou
avant de dire papa pratiquement
pratiquement allait bien stéphane
millette a dit propos alors pour leader
était jamais premier pourquoi il avait
un mauvais dealers ou quoi non non je
pense que il y en a bien qui était plus
fort que lui au dessus sans doute alors
sophie vous publié aujourd'hui chez
grasset un livre qui s'appelle pour
l'amour de jacques c'est une histoire
absolument incroyable qu'on va prendre
dès le début et calmement il vaut mieux
oui alors quand jacques anquetil
rencontre sa femme jeanine elle est
mariée à un médecin qui est l'ami de
jacques anquetil qui est un petit peu le
celui qui le suit non bah disons que
c'est son médecin et en même temps je
pense que fin juin quand il est fasciné
par en fait la classe sociale qu'il
représente et l'homme en lui-même qu'un
homme un peu de science était très
passionné par par la science la nature
donc il est fasciné par bach c'est ce
notable normand qui en plus sont
médecins donc les deux hommes
s'apprécient et la femme de ce notable
normande ce médecin qui tiendra madame
jacques anquetil est une très très jolie
femme a vraiment que faire maintenant
martine carol inquiète vraiment blonde
comme ça très très jolie elle a deux
enfants avec ce médecin est là annie et
alain voilà et jacques anquetil votre
père tombe raide amoureux de cette femme
il est fasciné par l au départ elle
n'est pas
gagnez pas du tout intéressé au départ
dont ils ne voient un peu comme si un
petit paysan un peu un peu péquenots
comme elle dit en fait
et puis un jour elle était en vacances
avec ses deux enfants à villefranche et
là elle cède ses venues en fait la durée
plusieurs années on partait souvent en
vacances ensemble est plus petit à petit
elle a appris à l'apprécier et puis elle
a succombé on va dire à son charme
voilà l coucher avec lui elle dit au
petit matin le lendemain matin je savais
que j'aimerais jacques totalement
jusqu'à la mort
belle histoire alors voilà donc au début
c'est une passion au plan destiné entre
jeanine et jacques anquetil
ensuite ils vivent horse il est quand
même des péripéties au moment du divorce
le toubib ils séquestrent sa femme un
moment non oui enfin c'est disons que je
vous remettent aussi de dans le contexte
des années fin de différentes sphères
des années 50 début des années 60 où
c'était ça se faisait pas je veux dire
les gens de divorcer pas en plus bon
c'était pour aller avec un homme public
enfin c'est un truc c'est quoi alors les
enfants restent avec leur père au départ
chez le médecin et puis comment sa fugue
y est allé de plus en plus souvent dans
la maison de jeanine et jacques et ils
finissent par vivre avec leur mère à
leur beau père pour disons que leur père
finit par capituler devant devant
l'insistance des enfants à toujours
vouloir en fait état était fasciné par
par l'avicca vie qu'avait ce couple en
fait qui était déjà très beau qui était
en plus qui voyagent et qui les emmenait
de partout à travers le monde donc fin
des années 60 de voyager au bout du
monde c'était sympa comme en lançant là
le toubib coupe les ponts et on le
reverra plus jamais donnera plus jamais
de nouvelles voilà ça c'est fin du
premier épisode est ce que tu suis
laurent oui toubib jeanine toubib deux
enfants jacques anquetil voilà tu suis
les notes je suis bien alors ça c'est
fin du premier épisode et bien ensuite
congé quand ils arrêtent le vélo au
début des années 70 il a 36 ans et puis
d'un seul coup il se retrouve tout seul
dans sa grande propriété du château des
elfes 700 hectares et là d'un seul coup
il se rend compte qu'il a fait une
carrière formidable qu'il a fait du bon
travail en tant que coureur cycliste
mais qui n'a pas de descendance il n'a
pas d'enfant
il va en avoir en fait il était en plus
c'était un homme qui était fasciné par
par le miracle de la nature
c'était quelque chose mais bon ffu des
bébés il adorait les enfants et puis toi
et ça fabuleux le fait de mettre au
monde et ce qu'il faut savoir ce qui est
très important c'est que elle a deux
enfants par césarienne deux
accouchements très difficile et son
médecin en fait façon mon mari pardon de
médecins lui à ligaturer les trompes
estimant que c'était dangereux pour elle
et sa santé d'avoir d'autres enfants
donc il ne peut pas avoir d'enfant avec
jeanine et il est très embêté parce
qu'ils l'aiment et il dit il faut que je
trouve une mère porteuse c'est la seule
solution
et à un moment il pense même aller voir
une prostituée dit on va prendre une
[ __ ]
a paris il est prêt à partir à paris
pour chercher quelqu'un est près
n'importe quoi pour trouver quelqu'un
voilà alors évidemment à ce moment-là
jeanine et tourmenté elle se dit quand
même c'est incroyable comme mon mari
soit obligé de faire ça elle cherche et
puis petit à petit une idée vient
insidieusement comme ça en elle
ça serait l'idée de de donner sa fille
annie à jacques anquetil et oui elle
demande à sa fille de cartes et je vais
décrire mariage je suis né voilà elle
veut qu'il soit heureux et elle se dit
en fait que disons pour avoir un enfant
plus près d'elle quelque part ça devient
comme une évidence elle qu'il n'ya que
sa fille qu'est capable enfin disons que
j'ai le mieux parce que s'adresse
vraiment à la maison et c'est
pour moi c'est magnifique c'est une don
extraordinaire ce qui veut dire quand
même c'est que annie votre mère donc
n'accepte pas sous la contrainte on ne
force pas il faut dire les choses quand
même un lui en parler lui et lui
demandait ce que tu accepterais c'est
une mission tête c'est une mission de
procréation cas là au départ mais je
pense que dès le début elle a toujours
été fascinée par lui quand elle était
petite et admiratif de l'ordre en plus
bon c'est un jeu c'est un très bel homme
donc elle n'a pas de difficulté à
succomber à son charme
alors ce qu'il faut dire évidemment
c'est que votre mère a nuit n'était pas
la fille biologique de jacques anquetil
donc à part il n ya pas d un crs en même
temps comme ils l'avaient enlevé et
quand même un petit peu incestueux parce
qu'il l'a dit oui et ellen quoi oui un
petit peu
voilà c'est un peu incestueux quand même
parce qu'il avait il avait élevé oui
c'était sa petite fille sous la forme
web voilà alors voilà donc vous
retrouver vous avec deux mamans dont
l'une est la fille de l'autre là on me
dit ça voilà alors au début jacques
anquetil s'est dit on va faire
reconnaître la maternité djahnine par
l'administration mais ça marche pas non
mais c'est à dire qu en fait au départ
à l'époque quand je suis né chine en 71
et la loi pour reconnaître ces enfants
naturels et patient 72 ça l'embêtait
beaucoup que je ne porte pas son nom bre
envie de me faire un peu passer pour
l'un pour la fille de sa femme
ce qui n'a pas pu être possible parce
qu'à dix quand même faut pas exagérer et
l'année d'après il m'a reconnu et j'ai
porté son voilà alors serez pu en rester
là
c'est à dire si à ce moment là votre
mère annie était parti faire sa vie aux
autres par serez plus en rester là mais
le problème c'est qu'au delà de cette
mission de procréation votre mère reste
dans le lit de jacques anquetil voilà et
ils sont pas restés juste le temps de
faire le moment ils sont restés 12 ans
quand même vie et le soir jacques
anquetil commencé la nuit dans le lit de
ni la maman de sophie et ensuite il
rejoignait le lit de jeanine la maman
dany oui je vais faire un schéma c'est
mais tout ça se passe très bien ce qu'il
faut dire quand même ceux qui n'y a pas
de voie là ya pas de violence tout
l'hexagone n'ont pas moi il ya toujours
des petits c'est à dire je pars dans un
coup il ya des fois des
déjà des petites tensions donc à trois
c'est plus compliqué mais non dans
l'ensemble yacine jalouse et un peu de
merfy ça se passe bien quoi je veux dire
c'est pas c'est pas un truc il dit ce
n'est pas tous les jours qu'on va tout
va bien il ya des fois des petites
engueulades mais parfois comme partout
dans tout couple c'est à dire 12 ans que
cette espèce de vie comme ça dure 12 ans
et un moment votre mère quand même
rencontre quelqu'un qui veut dire enfin
la vie c'est pas ça à dijon le temps
passe et puis elle voit en fait les
ailes elle voit sa jeunesse un peu
partir est là elle a toujours vécu sous
l'emprise en fait de son beau père et de
sa mère et un moment donné elle a besoin
de devises saviez donc elle décide de
partir les la première qui a su dire non
je m'en vais a ajouté c'est difficile de
dire non à jacques anquetil parce que
c'était un moment dans votre lit
d'ailleurs c'était insultes orientale
quoi c'est quelqu'un dont on avait du
mal à a pas observé les ordres oui
quelqu'un qui était très ouvert qui a
accepté facilement la conversation mais
il était dans la subtilité on va dire
il arrivait à voir tout peut arriver
toujours à ses fins un sens qu'on ait
l'impression que ça soit lui qu'il ait
voulu mais bon voilà en tous les cas
jacques anquetil ne se remet pas du
départ d'annie devient il ya un malade
d'amour quoi d'ailleurs c'est peut-être
ça qui lui a filé sans son cancer j'en
sais rien mais toujours est il que c'est
de ça dont il mourra quelques années
plus tard et lin jeanine sa femme
demande alain son fils et à sa femme
dominique de venir habiter avec eux
enfin pas habiter nanterre qui se voyait
plus trop parce que
hanine s'entendait pas bien avec
dominique sa part deux colonnes mais
c'est face il y avait une gomme et des
feutres à ce moment là jeanine donc
demande à son fils alain et à sa femme
dominique devenir vivent près de sessa
passait pas de vivre et de cirque au
départ on habitait tous ensemble et ma
mère en fait ne dit encore dominique est
arrivé à la maison ça a été quelque part
une forme de trou entre les parce que
bon déjà il était de une troisième bon
c'est sa vie un peu compliqué à gérer
tout le monde sous le même toit et elles
se sont disputés en fait est que mon
oncle est partie vivre de l'autre côté
droit à ce moment là donc anctil se sert
de dominique pourre en bras ni jalouse
et pourrait si la faire revenir
oulala c'est le diable encore encore ma
mère 120
manou en fait tu décides de recréer un
million de dire à son fils de revenir
plus souvent à la maison puisque en fait
annie n'est plus là pour empêcher le oui
bordeaux rentrée à ninon et parce qu'on
a peur on l'appelle tout cela nous en
fait c'est un petit nom qu'elle a entre
nous et est donc elle ramène son fils à
la maison et sa belle fille qui viennent
régulièrement
alors elle n'est plus du tout hélas
germe une idée extraordinaire dans la
tête de mon père très tacticien de dire
bah finalement pour embêter annie je
vais peut-être
m dominique ce qui manque pas de faire
voilà ce qui fait voilà mais alors
mis à l'essai à lédenon ton oncle wii
qui en même temps
ton frère tout alors juste si haut c'est
vrai qu'au niveau des titres ses
nombreux antécédents boy total va dire
que mon oncle et mon frère enfin c'est
mon demi-frère quelques façons mon frère
par le titre ça c'est mon parrain en
plus donc c'est vraiment un peu compte
n'y était pas jaloux que sa merci
l'élan avait 4 ans qui finissent au
chili sort absolument incroyable puisque
donc anctil après avoir été avec la mère
de sophie se met avec la femme du frère
de sophie avec dominique et un enfant
encore il un enfant qui est vote et
motive mon frère que votre frère qui
s'appelle christopher christopher voilà
et donc avec mon cousin germain jeune
frère en commun benjamin c'est le prénom
c'est le côté là il faut ordonner sa
journée malgré tout ça malgré la
naissance de ce christopher jacques
anquetil ne renonce pas à annie et elle
dit un jour bon bah je reviens 6,7
dominique 120 immédiatement et alors lui
lui dit non et dit non non je vais
attendre d'abord le baptême de
christopher donc elle revient pas sinon
elle serait revenue à votre mère avec
des cieux un ouais voilà et c'est la
veille du baptême de christopher qui
découvrira qu'il a un cancer voilà ça
c'est les pilotes de l'histoire
donc il a il a attendu ce baptême la
haie et la veille la prends cette triste
nouvelle
et c'est dominique ce qu'il faut dire
quand même je la connais pas mais enfin
elle s'occupera lui jusqu'à sa mort oui
une ambition elle accompagnera jusqu'au
bout je pense qu'elle a été très
amoureuse lui aussi aussi bien sûr
toutes les femmes étaient amoureux mais
énormément on voulait des montages et en
latin en franglais
pas d'un test dans la danse et je
voulais anticipé mais j'aime mieux à une
question oui est ce que est ce que ton
père donc est ce qu'il avait dans son
coeur assez d'amour pour donner à tous
pour que tout le monde soit klein vous
donne aujourd'hui condé double vie avec
des maîtresses et quand je pense au pire
l'homme pour moi il foncièrement bigame
à la base il a du poggio elle vient tous
les cas ça n'a pas été facile pour vous
ça quand même été une enfance un petit
peu compliqué non l'enfance non parce
que toute ma petite enfance a été génial
enfin je veux dire deux mamans c'est top
c'est doublement d'amour s'ils ont pu
vous saviez vous saviez la vérité quand
il a toujours su mais c'est vrai que
j'ai enfin j
on se rappelle pas quand est ce qu'on a
appris à marcher moi je me rate un j'ai
toujours su qui était ma mère n'a jamais
été cachés me dire c'est un homme qui a
eu finalement le courage de mettre sa
femme et sa maîtresse sous le même toit
et faire ça avec beaucoup d'amour et
dans une entente extraordinaire vous
accepteriez je pense que si si oui
effectivement si un homme a vraiment
cette générosité du coeur que je me sens
pas lésés que baye et que va mal et a ce
charisme qui fait kim envoûte
ouais et qui me donne satisfaction je
pense que oui je pense qu'on peut en
plus ils ont une histoire de famille
sait pas si des hommes seraient capables
d'accepter inverse
en tous les cas à vous ça vous a pas
spécialement perturbé en tous les cas
vous avez l'air plus tôt plutôt cool
mais vous êtes quand même partie un
petit peu en amérique latine un petit
peu au mexique un moment oui enfin je
suis partie non mais ça c'était enfin
disons qu'après je me suis un peu
cherché mais comme toute personne peut
chercher un moment donné
bon voilà on suit son chemin c'est vrai
qu'il ya des moments plus ou moins
difficiles vont mal à l'adolescence n'a
pas été facile pour eux d'avoir sa tante
qui devient du jour au lendemain sa
belle mère quand on est en pleine crise
d'adolescence de perdre son père à 16
ans et ni bon c'est pas l'idéal quand
même mais mais sinon sur tout le reste
mange vraiment été très heureuse quoi
aujourd'hui ça va vous vivez bien je vis
encore dans un endroit magnifique
au bout du monde j'ai fait un croquis de
la corse avec avec joël c'est ça et vous
avez un enfant s'appelle yaneka six ans
vous avez des guerriers lui le papa
vouliez imposant alors ce qui est drôle
même famille
le plus incroyable de la perse et conan
ou jeannine vie là bas aussi ensemble
mais aussi à trois kilomètres où j'avais
recréer ça là-bas tout à fait le plan c
en reconstituant qui avoue il ya votre
maman et je sais votre grand-mère là
c'est ça elles ont lu le bouquin
oui bah elles ont toutes qu avant
dominique aussi du reste avant que le
grand bleu sorti un même jeu rennais
leur avis qu'elles vont penser seulement
elle était d'accord
ben oui enfin ils ont trouvé deux mines
et qu'elle a gardée la propriété elle
quand même c'est mon frère qui a là non
c'est non à temps annoncé plus tôt par
dont la maison est à lui retranché lors
quel vélo tu n'as pas parce que j'en
fais pas dit il ce qui est incroyable
c'est que ça a pas laissé beaucoup de
traces finalement c'est un peu comme le
jeu pas si vous avez vu le bouquin de
franz olivier giesbert celle de
l'américain le wagon des choses
terribles qui dut sont arrivés pendant
son enfance et son adolescence et
finalement il n'en est sorti assez
indemme bizarrement c'est pour ça que
c'est bizarre je veux dire oui il ya des
gens qui manquent d'amour dans plein de
choses moi j'ai eu énormément d'amour
donc je pense qu'il ya de l'amour dans
quelque chose quelque part on se
rééquilibre je veux dire y'a pas de on
peut avoir des moments de déséquilibre
mais l'amour est plus fort que tout vous
saviez depuis toujours que vous raconter
cette histoire un jour quelque part je
l'avais en moi j'ai toujours dit quand
j'étais petit
un jour je raconterai cette histoire est
j'aime bien écrire donc bon l'un dans
l'autre et un moment donné est venu donc
après avoir vu un enfant peut-être
d'être bien stable avec tout le monde
autour de moi je me suis dit finalement
ça serait bien d'écrire ce livre déjà
pour me prouver à moi même que je suis
que j'étais capable de le faire de
raconter ça et puis ça a été enfin il ya
eu des petites des petites choses que
j'ai entendu des fois des petits
dérapages de gens de l'extérieur qui se
permettait de dire qu avait eu vent ou
indues des bruits sur ma situation
familiale
je me suis finalement s'il ya quelqu'un
qui a le droit de raconter cette
histoire c'est moi et je trouve que
signe que les bruits que ce soit vous
quelqu'un d'extérieur qui l'avait
raconté déjà on ne peut pas la
comprendre si on n'est pas à l'intérieur
et en plus c'est quand même une très
belle histoire d'amour mais ce qui est
incroyable c'est que ce soit ce soit pas
sorti finalement c'est pas une énorme
star et tout le charisme de l'âme
est ce que le cancer il a eu à cause du
dopage alors moi je vous réponds à la
question suivante je ne sais pas ce
qu'est ce qu'un enfant de 8 ans qui aime
leucémie c'est à cause du dopage
je ne sais pas le constat en quelque
chose qui ne s'explique pas ça se
déclenche chez n'importe qui n'importe
comment est-ce que le dopage aurait
favorisé le démarrage du cancer ça il en
prenait un petit peu comme vous le dites
dans votre bouquin il a été le premier a
été le premier coureur vous me dire a
avoué enfin dire que
il gagne pas un tour de france avec un
morceau de sucre qui en a parlé
publiquement et il a dit si personne
n'en prenais je n'en prendrai pas est ce
que j'explique aussi dans le livre moi
le dopage c'est sûr quand je vois ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui c'est assez triste
quoi joue alors ça me fait mal au coeur
mais c'était pas du tout
la même chose à l'époque enfin c'était
beaucoup plus gentil on va dire vous
pensez qu'ils en pensent quoi si vous
voilà ce soir d'un je pense que quelque
part ça ferait sourire
ouais ouais franchement l'ambiguïté du
personnage pour la mort de jack 7 ans
j'ai tracé
et maintenant
et
m